welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz
today i'm really excited to be joined by
james branton who is the co-founder of
2b talent solutions which he founded
with his brother in 2013.
as a business they partner with high
growth b2b
tech companies across europe and are
based out of manchester
james entered the recruitment industry
in 2008
straight out of university where he
worked for one agency
and over four years progressed from
trainee to the head of
uh his division before taking the leap
to set up his very own recruitment
business to be
talent solutions with his brother in
2013.
james welcome to the podcast thank you
for having me hisham
pleasure to be here my man so where we
always like to start
is so in your opinion what
characteristics and traits do you think
make up
a highly successful recruitment
consultant
yeah i think we spoke about this before
i think
i guess overall there's certain
characteristics and you've got you've
got to look at the type of recruitment
as well i suppose right
so you know depend depending on what
they're doing for contract it might be a
more salesperson for
you know senior permit might need a
slightly different relationship based
approach
i guess like overall the stuff that
you're gonna need is
you know good resilience it's the usual
stuff right so
a very ambitious mindset um ability to
take rejection
um you know sales focus um
but the stuff that kind of i think that
works well is like
number one is i see a passion for people
right so
the way we kind of look at it is if
someone's to be six
in our market and we work for a fairly
senior perm market right
so it's a lot about relationships and
engaging with senior people and they're
probably getting
contacted by a load of recruiters and we
have to stand out with personality
basically
so passion for me i think like the
ability to actually have an interest in
what you're doing to convey that
interest have an interest in people
um and to want to kind of make a bit of
a change
is massive and i think that's overlooked
you know sometimes people go straight
like cut throat go for the cell
but you know really like taking your
time to engage in it understand why
you're interested in it because if you
have that why people are going to buy
into you more as a person
i'm more likely to work with you do you
know what i mean um
i think i think kind of moving on from
that
one thing that that is important is like
taking accountability so basically not
blaming people for when stuff goes wrong
you know only up to it
um and you know in this game you can go
into every month with a chance
to bill out you know 50 60 grand or more
and that can that could all come in that
could all drop off um
you've got to keep your mindset like
right well even if it does drop off and
moving forward
i'm not going to start blaming people
about what i've done here what i've done
wrong
i'll take ownership of it all we'll look
into the future anyway let's not get
hung up on that stuff
um and move forward then i guess on on
top of that mate like the way we do
things is that a very much a human
approach so i suppose it's like
emotional intelligence it's being able
to put yourself
in the kind of shoes of the person
you're trying to engage whether it's a
client or candidate
and try and kind of see see what they
want to hear what do they want from this
um i think sometimes people can get
wrapped up in the what am i selling or
what am i giving
but you've got to kind of take a step
back and think about what what do they
want to hear from me even it's like
constructing an inmail for
linkedin recruiter you know it's like
just making sure that
you're gonna convey the points that
people want to hear and not all this
like jargon crap that no one cares about
you know what i mean it's like put
yourself in the in those in those shoes
so
that's it mate you know the deal the
list's endless right but
yeah i think i love that do you
do you think just i think i love the
accountability piece that's something
that i had to
i sort of felt like early on in my
career early on in my career
especially in sales like i had to when i
started reading like self-development
books and stuff like that that was like
one of the main things that i took was
like
i am completely responsible for like
where i end up
rather than pointing the finger at hey
because that's happened that's why i'm
not here
so guess do you the the question is like
do you see that lack of accountability
in
consultants when you hire them or early
on in their career do you think
sometimes that can lack
yeah well i think so i think
i guess this is like a trait that's
quite hard to build right and you've got
to be honest and there's different types
of accountability so
yes you're accountable for your own
learning but then also the team that you
work with are accountable to you but
if someone someone is like either going
to blame someone for their
failure or they're going to take it on
themselves you know what i mean and it's
that sort of mentality of
i'm in control of what i'm doing yes
there's factors that i can't influence
but everything that i can i'm going to
do to my best possible way and that's my
responsibility
and if if the stuff that you can't
control fails and you move on you have
to you have to understand that's not
your fault you get you get past it
basically so
i i've seen it i think we obviously
interview a lot of graduate profiles
right and i think
you can even hear like the difference in
mindset people talking through the
career oh you know what what happened to
the others oh well
something bad happened and and they
blame me on someone
whereas someone even at a junior age
it's hard on you but they're like right
i take full responsibility i
you know took my eye off the ball i was
enjoying the social side of it too much
we hear people say that listen social
sec of the
of the union that's why i got a 2-2 but
it's like it's someone owning up to that
right from the start and i think i think
that's that mindset and that
characteristic that you want that i want
to see anyway is like we all make
mistakes and that none of us are perfect
and i think for particularly for younger
people who are getting into it
own own it yourself own your flaws and
your positives and
that self-awareness and also that
accountability will shine through for
anyone
clients candidates or any employer that
you're looking for as well without doubt
yeah i love that so look we're going to
talk about your
sort of journey in being a business
owner with your brother but
let's just first start we'll just start
firstly like so you join obviously going
to the recruitment industry out
straight out of university so i guess
look always interested to hear like how
would you describe your first gym
recruitment
what was that like it was interesting
all right so um i like i think
probably that quite a lot of people i
fell into recruitment i studied law
uh i did i really didn't want to go down
the law root is like right you've got to
progress every year for 50 years and
then you just you get better i didn't
want i knew i didn't want to do that
right but i
had an all right degree and then my
friend was working with him he's like
i'm making good dough i was like it
sounds like something i could do you
know i mean i'm keen for that so
there's actually me and rick my brother
for anyone who's watching we joined
three days apart the same company right
um but we both have about
ourselves into it and i got put on the
finance finance team as it was back then
um first six months i was basically
doing a resourcer role
because one of my manager had an
accountant and then it just wasn't
working right i wasn't like i've seen
everyone else who started with me who
was billing who was doing well and i was
like right you know bugger this i'm just
going to take it on myself so
i just literally set it up without any
help from a boss i've got a list of
managing directors at investment banks
found the number on the switchboard and
just did it old school it was just
literally
there was no there's no linkedin even
back then there wasn't that heavy on for
what i was doing heavy on linkedin
it was getting like it was old school
getting candidates from a
you know from a um a cv like like a
e-financial careers i don't know what
you call we don't use a job board right
and um literally just qualifying them
and then speccing them into managing
directors i had no idea what i was doing
but it worked and i got set up and
running on that bit so
first year was like kind of
getting exposure to recruitment
understanding how it works realizing
that yeah i'm not going to do this
resources thing and then having to kind
of figure out myself
just literally by mapping out little
markets and picking up the phone and
hammering it basically
i probably have a lot of people who are
similar experience in the recruitment
industry to me started right
yeah um but it was fun like the first
year was fun it i enjoyed it like it was
exciting it was a roller coaster you
know you're out of uni
um you kind of you you're with a bunch
of other young people the company i mean
it was in the middle of the credit
crunch as well so it wasn't going to be
easy right but
that sort of looked back now i think if
you can make success in those times then
when it's
booming and it's starting to get that
way now then you can you know you can
have a lot of success
so yeah i enjoyed it mate like it was
really enjoyed it yeah
yeah talk to me about the dark days
though
early on like it doesn't have to be in
the first year but because i think
i love your positivity towards that and
i can really tell that
you really enjoyed it and made the most
of it and stuff like that but i think
yeah people want to know how did you
early on in those days when you can
you're a bit more prone to maybe quit
or like think recruitment's not for me
like talk to talk to us about some low
days that you really had to
dig deep to push on yeah i mean
the low days i might sound positive but
looking back it's it's always 50 50
positive and
negative right there's some real dark
days right but you have to
i only look back and look at the
positives because that's the stuff
you've learned from it
there's no point looking back and seeing
as negative any bad experience provided
you've learned from it it's a positive
right but
the the dark days were bad you know like
back then you didn't it was
i didn't have the experience i had now i
didn't know how to qualify candidates i
was
you know had people at like late stages
thinking it would happen i had i
remember had one month right and i was
i was like eight months into my
recruitment career and i just moved from
doing the resource so i just set up this
little market investment management it
was called
and had these two people at final stage
both 15 grand fees and back then it was
like that was
that was big so i was like yeah i was
like buzzing right you know you sat
there aren't you in recruiting you're
counting up your commission you're
telling all the boys on the floor i'm
gonna smash it this month
and actually last last day of the month
when we were supposed to sign contracts
both dropped off
and it's just like i was just like oh my
lord because
well there's a lesson learned but listen
don't talk about anything until it's
done right
because that's what recruiters do don't
they we sit here we're all like buzzing
off it you're telling everyone how much
permission you're gonna make
until it's done it's done um but i
remember back then
the the actual owner of the company was
quite like a firm person you know i
didn't mind it but i was like i think i
always respected the way he sort of
handled it all but
um i noticed he was just like listen you
know make sure he's all right because
obviously you've lost the deals and
stuff said to my boss
at the time and i just think seems to
remember thinking like
and i suppose you're quite lucky with
this was that when that happened i was
just like right
no one else can sort this out but me so
i'm gonna have to go back even harder
like you annoyed for
you know a couple hours or the rest of
the day it's friday so we have some
beers
but then after that it's just picked
back up right how can i get better how
can i do more
and i think it was actually a point
right is that
maybe talk about this a bit late or
whatever but in terms of mindset that
was saying is that
if you kind of the problem that a lot of
like recruiters have is they'll have a
big month you know they sat there all
happy and then they'll take the foot off
the gas a little bit
if you can get your mindset into that
feeling that everything will drop
out and you have to rebound back and if
you're constantly in that mindset
of having to fight back and drive back
then
that's when you create monster billers
basically people who are
always thinking regardless of what
success they've had assume it was
negative and move forward basically
talk about that in a bit type stuff but
yeah yeah the days are dark but you have
to just pick yourself up
you know it's no one else is going to do
it for you so
so i guess just just focusing on this
point a bit because i'm sure you've now
have to
in those days and and now with your own
business but like
when you can see someone's in a bit of a
funk they've had dropouts they've
blanked for the second month in a row or
whatever
like sometimes it can be really hard to
sort of see that perspective
right and that's something that yeah the
the best recruiters get
better at so guess what sort of things
people listen to this that may be going
through that now or may have experienced
that a lot i don't know what would you
typically try and communicate and convey
to your people people in your team your
business who you can see a
sort of experience now and going going
through that first hand what would you
sort of communicate to them i mean let's
try and get out of it
yeah of course yeah yeah i mean it's a
good one and it's how you've got a
manager i i guess what i'd always say is
that
there's two things first of all remember
like you got this job you've done this
job
if you've not had success before you
know if you if stage you've not had if
you're just literally brand new and
you're struggling with it all
remember that you went through an
interview process and they like for it
think about all the good traits that you
have you're good at
reflect on yourself you'll be grateful
for the fact that you've got the
opportunity to stop looking at external
things to blame
or whatever it may be but focus back on
it and the way i kind of do the team is
that
you have to make sure that the if you if
i believe in one of the team
and and they have a bad patch then it's
up to me to
convey to them like this and you know we
believe in you we value you
you are good at this it's trying to
bring back that positive mindset
um but i think yeah it you know
it's a tough one i think good coaching
um
trying to not get too wrapped up in it
once you start getting into a bit of a
funk
start making mistakes right or you start
forcing the issue and that can lead you
into a bigger funk
so the way i kind of look at it is over
a weekend or whatever have a reset
do a little bit of an exercise i think
like showing gratitude or thinking i
know it sounds a bit mad for some people
but
think of all the good stuff that you've
got in your life and then come back
reset
restart fresh either think back to what
you've had success with before talk to
your manager about how you can
make things better um but remember like
yeah don't get too wrapped up in it the
negativity breeds negativity such any
way you can try and get it out of your
mind
and reset yourself and come back
stronger and focus on the key things
that you were good at
you've had success in the past that you
might have forgotten about i guess
yeah it's such a it's such a it's a
tough it's a tough question
because everyone gets down about
different stuff don't they so it's hard
to actually gauge that one but
you know from a leadership point of view
good coaching positive positivity
helping out with any training that they
need reassurances that you
that you rate them and don't create a
positive don't create an environment
where if someone isn't doing well
they're they feel like the
that the black sheep of the company you
know um
the fact is yeah yeah i was just gonna
say um
no i think what you said is great i
think it's basically to to put that all
together it's the
yes look it's absolutely fine to be in
the funk that's fine like
go through that but i think what you do
want to do and how you're going to get
better at making sure you snap out of it
is
finding the things to focus on that you
did do well or finding the things to
focus on that you're grateful for or
whatever and
you it's like a muscle isn't it like you
it's like now
if you've always tried to find those
things as soon as something bad happens
you're just going to be quicker at
finding the things that
you can't deposit as you can take away
from it and stuff like that
yeah and couple that with set little
goals right so you know
the goal might be to to get a fee to do
a deal but right that might be
that might seem so distant that you mind
can't even believe it yeah
so so set little smaller goals to reach
that and then plan that so every day
every
week you know you're going towards that
target and that'll create a more
positive mindset
rather than just focusing on the stuff
the fact that you might not have any
money on the board or you blanks for a
few months whatever it may be
little wins that'll keep the positive
mindset basically yeah i love that
so look final question really on sort of
you being employed
before we go into starting your own
business i guess
what what i did notice and what a lot of
recruiters aspire to listen to his
podcast is is to progress their career
right is to
get that promotion is to become that
leader or direct or whatever so i guess
obviously notice that you progressed
quite quickly and it seems like you
really took the initiative to do things
and um
and take action but i guess why why do
you think james was the person that was
able to progress and get to that head-up
position
um i mean head off position i was only
managing a team of two it was more for
the
linkedin but but you know in reality i
i did like from scratch set up two
markets and the last one was the one we
ended up leaving the business and we
kind of based our company at the moment
on it all but yeah
i think um what what what helped me out
was
um i had i've got an inquisitive mindset
i want to understand how things work
i love like i love talking to people and
understanding like listening to them as
well i think not just talking to people
it's understanding
more about those guys um and i think
i've got a little bit i like i
it's that it's probably built into a lot
of people or you can maybe train it but
i've got no problem with working hard um
but i am a little bit lazy right so i'm
always trying to think how can i work
smarter how can we do things better
how can we like how can we reduce the
workload right so if
i know it's a bit mad right but if
you're if you had to be as efficient as
possible because you're lazy as possible
i know i say it right but how
what things would you focus on right
well then then you focus on
all those things when you're not lazy
it'll just go
it'll go crazy so try and i was always
looking at
different ways in which i can stand out
from other recruiters that were
pestering them or bothering them you
know what i mean or
any way i can make an impact with these
guys
um and that was like it's just little
stuff like remembering birthdays it was
following up it was
asking questions making notes a bit
about the family about the friends about
anything that's coming up
something that's going to make them
remember me and want to work with me in
the future
and i think these are the things and
then then i guess on top of that what
i'll learn pretty quickly after that
first thing i'll tell you about when
those deals dropped out
is like be straight with your processes
and understand how to do that so that
was another thing
don't get caught up in the what could
happen focus on what is happening and
what will happen
and then you know keep looking forward
rather than rather than looking back i
suppose
um okay so final point on this then is
like i guess knowing what you know now
what
what advice would you give that sort of
james stroud uni got the law degree what
advice would you give him going into
that first recruitment job
um i mean i'm looking back i wouldn't
really change too much so i mean just
just keep keep keep doing what you do i
think you know in height
in hindsight i'd have you know looked at
a different market earlier out of out of
you know being more focused but you're
learning as a person
it's hard for me to say history because
i wouldn't i wouldn't change too much
right
because everything was part of the
learning but i think anyone who's early
in the recruitment
um phases you know if they're having a
good time keep focused work even harder
be that you know
be best don't stop don't look at anybody
else around you just focus on your stuff
and if you're having a really tough time
i guess assess assess everything around
you are you having a tough time because
you know you're not getting the right
support look at the external factors not
saying blame someone but it might be
that you're not right for that
that situation or that market wherever
it may be or it might be that you're
just not like
doing the right thing so trying to keep
that self-awareness about what's going
on with your
career basically that would be my advice
i love that so
a lot of people think about starting a
recruitment business but not a lot of
people
make that first step so talk to us about
what what gave you the courage to take
that first step
because how old was you when you started
when you took that first step 26
yeah so talk to us about what gave you
the courage why was you able to take
that first step do you think
well yeah the courage is more born out
of having a problem with authority right
so
i think i think no this is right so the
company that i worked for um you know
now they're doing really successful so i
can't say anything bad about them but
i think at the time you know they'd come
out of a credit crunch it was
the company was expanding but there
probably wasn't a massive focus
on kind of employee development right on
a career path and all this sort of stuff
that is important now
um so i guess on top of that so i was
having success in the market
they wanted to be very heavy telephone
based our market required more
relationship based there wasn't
switchboards to get through to you had
to be
good with your written word with your
emails and relationship building
um so i guess it was wanting to do
things more
our way so being a bit stubborn having a
problem with like not really being
nurturing the the career path and the
staff
but then also wanting to make all the
money for ourselves instead of making
commissions so
you know it comes to the point i don't
only done it for it's actually three
years i've done it for
and yeah we just thought right this
feels like the right time you know
um and took the plunge but i think we've
always like
my brother and i have always been pretty
confident back ourselves and
um i think on top of that yeah i knew
the market was
going to go off so we were like right
well if we don't do it now then we could
just
we could never do it basically if you
see the opportunity
anyone who's watching this take that
opportunity you can always go back into
a recruitment job but go for it if you
get the chance to go for it
yeah so just to just to frame it up for
people
then so just to painting a picture so
obviously started the business you and
your brother
and then obviously it's been going for
what how long that eight years
is it looks like eight years yeah yeah
yeah it's a really solid amount of time
so like just paint i know that i know
there would have been peaks and troughs
right but
obviously just you to the beginning how
long was it just roughly
like just you two and then where are you
like today
as a business and and stuff like that
and then we'll dive into
parts of this journey yeah of course
mate yeah i'll give you a little bit of
a heads up i suppose so
the the idea when we set it up was kind
of
you know we didn't really know how to
scale the company or anything right so
we just thought right
what we'll do is we did it on a
shoestring we'll set ourselves up
pretty much exactly like we were working
before but in our own little windowless
regis office
and in all honesty for the first few
years it was just about
like perfecting our craft with how we
did recruitment it was about
building up our financial resources so
we've never had any external investment
or any debt as a business
so it was about right the main driver
was never wanting to work for anybody
else again right so that's the first
thing you're thinking about and then
that develops from there it's like right
well the market's really good
we have a lot more freedom to do things
as we want to do and we have a lot more
freedom in our lives as well so
for the first few years we
um and i've got i suppose we've got a
good point on this one for the first few
years
we just worked rick and i and then it
came to the point
where we actually tried hiring a couple
of people and despite i was leading a
small team
um the old company didn't really have
any experience of building a company
right so yeah um we tried hiring a
couple of people and we
and you know they did okay but we didn't
we didn't know what we were doing in all
honesty we just thought about it it was
a bit finger in the wind and
guaranteed a lot of people will be doing
the same stuff and so what we started
doing we started attending networking
events
and as part of the networking events we
found a couple of people who are just
brilliant who now consult with us much
more senior who have been there and done
it all
and essentially the the learning from it
is to to go and get the advice
right if you don't know it go and seek
out people out there will tell you how
to stuff with your recruitment mentors
anybody who feels like they don't know
something go and seek out that advice
right
um you know find people to do it um and
if you can you know
go to these networking events and have a
bit of fun listen and learn and find
people who are
more seniors than you are i've been
there and done it get them to like you
and hopefully then they'll give you
advice either for free or for cheap and
that's that's a bit of a plan with it
all
but one point i wanted to make right so
the the thing that
i'd say to anybody who's in the state of
maybe thinking about going their own
right setting up on their own is stick
to
your brand of recruitment right so
everything that's got you where you are
stick to that and stick to it
religiously right because that's how you
do things that's what you've got
successful for and how you've been able
to do it
if you're thinking about then moving set
up a business and you your plan is to
scale it
but you haven't scaled the company
before get advice
i think for for me like one of the
probably mistakes that we made was that
when we set the business up i always
thought recruitment
is like everyone's a bit gray it's all a
bit like you know i didn't really
have any mentors in the recruitment
world that i respected
and i probably switched off from getting
advice
because i thought they'd try and change
the way we were doing our recruitment
when when our brand feedback from
clients was brilliant what we were doing
was amazing
but what i should have done in hindsight
is you know
not as big as maybe arrogant or stubborn
and then
under understood i don't know how to
scale the business so now go and get
that advice so
that's probably what would have delayed
things a little bit but we learned
pretty quickly when we had a bit
it was about a year of trying and then
we started attending networking events
so
i guess to bring it back we probably
it's about three and a half years of
just working ourselves
yeah then we tried hiring a little bit
didn't work out and then
over the last two and a half three years
is where we've been really giving it a
go
yeah just like just wait you sat there
and you know in your head but once
someone who's been there and done it
explains it to you
just like oh my god that's so simple to
understand you know i mean he's like why
haven't we doing this the whole time
knowledge is so important and then and
then then once you know that then you
put in all the little things
and then you make it personal to you you
get the knowledge and then you make it
personal to you but at the start i just
thought right ignore
everybody we're doing it our way when we
should have been more
open to ideas and more about learning
and stuff so
yeah yeah we really appreciate the
honesty on that so i guess
just just let's just let's just zoom in
on that for a second because i i
think i'd like to think the types of
people that would start a recruitment
business
it today would be more open to take
because there's just so much more stuff
out there that you can learn from
compared to
when you started in recruitment you know
what i mean it's a lot it was would have
been
even when i started in recruitment it
would like in 2016 it would have just
been a lot more easy to be insular
and just take everything that you know
about recruitment within your four walls
but i guess there's also a lot of people
that give you bad advice
right so yeah yes so let's just talk
about
like i know you said you went to
networking events got that so you put
yourself
out there gave yourself more
opportunities you and your brother to
meet people etc etc
but i guess i don't know talk to us a
bit about what people can do to make
sure that they're getting the right
advice i don't know what did you make
sure that you found out about this
person or what did you
what did you did you have any sort of
maybe non-negotiables on
what this person's experience had to be
like that gave you confidence they could
help you you know i mean like
maybe that could be some good advice for
people listening that could seek
help but then maybe they don't want to
get the bad advice i'm not sure
on that front yeah i mean listen the
first thing you'd look at is
whoever you're dealing with what's their
track record right i think
even before that do you connect with
this person right is the person that's
offering help or you want to get help
from do you personally get on with them
can do you have that rapport where you
can be honest with each other you can
talk to each other you can give a bit of
get a bit and
they're open to discussion as well um i
think then
um things you can do is then like i said
before look at their background right
has someone been there and done what you
want to do or they're doing it a bit
differently
um and then i guess like the the the
final things about getting bad advice is
if you feel that
the advice you're getting isn't right
typically
your gut is gonna be right right okay
there'll be things that maybe you're not
comfortable with that will help your
business that you'll have to change
but if you feel something isn't quite
right talk about it with your friends
talk about your family find other
mentors as well to cross-reference it on
the more help you can get the better and
the more people you can reference it
with the better
um and then just start building your
little network you have friends in
recruitment or the leaders an ex boss
whatever it may be people can pick up
the phones when you say this i'm just
running this past year is that okay
so the the more people to reference it
from a guest
is a key thing get getting on with the
person um
seeing their background see if they can
they've done what you want to do with
your business because everyone wants to
do like different stuff right
um and then you know keeping your
network open and referencing it for
advice basic i'd say
okay i love that talk to me about what's
it been like
it's you must have a good relationship
with your brother yeah you guys not
falling out before that's what's going
on
yeah we're trying to tell everybody when
they start like what's like working with
your brother like
well we like we chill on weekends like
it's the um the grand national on
saturday and
um he's just coming over to mine we're
going to get like a pork joint in the
in the oven for 24 hours we're going to
get watch the races have a few beers
we like it we have we have a good mix to
be fair what is difference
only 14 months so yeah oh wow okay yeah
i'm the younger one he's the older one
he just tells me what to do and i do it
basically that's right the
relationship's so good so
um but no we have we have a good set of
me and i think um
i think what what's that come first from
the relationship right is
is the fairness when we were kind of
brought up everyone in our
kind of friendship circle would come
around to our house and chill out we
treated everyone well we looked after
everybody and i think
as we grow the company one of our main
focuses is on looking after the staff
making sure they're kind of treated in
the fair way make sure respect's massive
we're not going to have any people like
bitching or moaning about stuff or
address issues that we have but
when people see that's how we interact
with each other as the founders of the
business and we have that built into our
dna
then it kind of sets a nice tone for
everybody else as well so yeah listen
we argue bad we've had times when we're
driving into manchester and he's jumped
out the car because we disagree on
something
and he's actually walked into the office
i've done the same to him so
you have the fiery times but that shows
passion so you can't you can't
you can't like hide away from that but
yeah we like it you know
there's ups and downs there's always
going to be ups and downs but the
positive is that you know
no neither going anywhere and you can
trust it all but it does it sets a nice
tone in the office for everybody else
you know that's how we interact we treat
people like each other generally unfair
absolutely so let's just let's just like
i want to dig into because a really
popular question i always get is around
sort of asking questions to people like
yourself who have
sort of yo-yo'd with the people the
amount of people you've had in the
business and the difficulties you've had
sort of hiring for your own business
that always seems to be like a common
challenge and
common thing that people find difficult
but i guess
something that would be really relevant
for people that are also
sort of employed is like how did you go
about
because i'm assuming you had covenants
right so i guess at the beginning of
this journey so i guess how did you go
about
building a market from scratch and like
i don't know what was your approach
there what ended up being
sort of the most successful way that you
and your brother got off to a good start
and how long did it take for you to do
your first deal and things like that
yeah so i mean so there's two two
questions there right so listen i don't
want to talk about the
the building the market bit yeah yeah
start there yeah if you start there and
then you remind me of the rest of the
questions because i forgot
to tell you right so for me building the
market was
i enjoy that right that's something that
that i like to do so
i guess what i'd always do is find your
little niche right whatever that's going
to be
what you're going to be focused on um
you know map it out research it
um then what we did is should it be
let's just talk about that
because you always hear that don't you
like how how neat should it be
that's such an open question because you
know the
the the nisha the better if that's even
a phrase yeah yeah
i i think like the
the difficulty is is that you've got
disciplines right and then you've got
like
types of companies and sectors almost
haven't you like as a yeah so you might
have sales and marketing as disciplines
then you might have that for you know
loads of different vertical companies
right yeah so typically what i'd be
looking at is
get one or two disciplines in one like
vertical so when we when we set the
business up it was fintechs online
payments
so we were like right all we're gonna do
is commercial people sales people for
online payments companies
so in a way that's a niche in itself
right okay yeah i got here
and then you've got location as well so
we set up and we just did europe wide
and
in reality we're probably going too far
like if you think about
if if you've got a research where where
there's a demand for
all right so and and you've got to kind
of map out the market from a talent
standpoint
which would help right is there enough
people is enough movement in this market
is the people to move between different
jobs then the key thing we've always
done i'm kind of waffling on a bit here
but the key thing we've always done
is speak to the people in the market
right we've always worked with high
growth startups and scale-ups
to speak to people in the market and
understand who are the new players that
are coming through
who are the companies that are changing
the game who people are admiring
you might just hear it from a couple of
people right but
if you hear a name that's coming up a
couple times and research that company
and spend your time trying to work with
that company it might take
a month it might take six months it
might take a year
our best client took me two years of
pestering to work with
and since then with those guys we've
made over 90 hires
across europe um the companies started
off with just one office
in the netherlands and now it's i think
they've got 25 offices worldwide they're
worth 60 billion
on the other listed a couple years ago
and the one of the best companies out
there
but that's because i started picking up
on people hearing about them talking
about them
and i was like right chief commercial
officer i am going to be working with
you in
in the next couple of years so whatever
it may be and then build relationships
with those people
it's very easy in recruitment to just
pick up work and that right now i'm just
going to work on anything that's out
there
focus your time you might need to do
that at the start particularly setting
your business or your desktop but
make sure you get back to this niche
right and this is kind of the message
that we've
a lot we've been doing over the last
sort of year and a half is narrowing our
focus a lot more
so really like before we were working
across five european countries and
everyone
every consultant might be doing those
five european countries and then the
disciplines within that sales marketing
customer success
and everything else and now we'll just
have someone on one country in one
discipline in one sector of the market
and get deep rather than why do you know
what i mean and i think
that's has that had a positive effect
then like how does that help
you guys without a doubt because like i
said
when you're in recruit it's quite easy
to get distracted and just take on work
everywhere you know yeah we can fill
that all right we can try and do that we
can do that but
you end up kind of going around in
circles if you stick to one
focus in one area you'll build your
reputation in that market
and you treat people well and then
you'll find out that you'll get a roll
on and guess what you've got the whole
candidate market covered for that and
this is obvious stuff but for people
starting up when you might be like
the market's growing so much or you're
trying to get different stuff yeah
it takes balls to turn down a roll that
might pay x amount
but if you think about it if you're
focused on germany for example yeah
and you're doing enterprise sales people
saying just in munich for example one
city in germany
if you just keep focusing on that but
someone goes all right i'm in paris i've
got this head of marketing role
he's paying 120 k you know we'll pay you
the big fee for it all it's tempting to
focus on that but in that time
you spent on the other role you're not
focusing on your key market
you the time that you're spending
elsewhere is not spending on the key
market so
there's always going to be a balance
right you've got to try and hit your
numbers for stuff but
as much as you can focus on the area
and the niche that you can do and
understand that the time that you spend
away from that is time where somebody
else is in that market building the
relationships that
that uh you should be building yeah no
no thank you look
no i'm really glad you went into that
because i know a lot of people
just really interested in like yeah how
much should i focus what should my niche
be
and things like that but the only other
question because i think it's just good
context for people because it'd be
something they're worried about was
how long did it go how long would it
take from
you and your brother setting up to
getting that first invoice paid
yeah um so we we yeah that was it but
we but we budgeted for we had a small
bit of money but we budgeted
unrealistically for to last as nine
months um
because what we were doing was quite
like seeing your perm stuff it was
taking
on average it was taking like six weeks
for the interview process to happen
and then the notice period then started
that invoice that's the way we were
doing it back then
um but we got quite lucky for that so we
we had like we had we made
we set up in february and then we did
our first
deals in um
in april early april so we had
the first deal was a person out of work
he was ace guy actually back in the day
i remember him he's a really cool guy
stay in touch from time to time but out
of work
um perfect match the interview process
took a week and a half
basically and then he was starting the
following week so we just like get in
there
and then we just kind of we we picked up
that
we did have covenants in place but
because i set the market up at my last
company
the the um the the clients weren't
getting the service no one knew what
they were doing that well back at the
company so they reached out to us
directly
and in the covenant if they reached out
to you that that covered it off so
in the meantime in the down time we had
between setting up there were messages
saying what's going on with it all
and then maybe just boom like like i
said every every bit of hope that we had
that did go
like seeing the market and taking the
risk just went went to plan for that
first bit
and we absolutely nailed it in our first
year we set the business in february and
we're not really taking any holidays in
the three years we did recruitment
we were in dubai in may for my birthday
on a holiday mate that's like this
one and then we had a great first year
and then second year
literally standard we were loving the
success we had a dry year maybe like we
we just took our eyes off the prize we
were young we're enjoying the success
and that was a lesson learned we like we
stopped doing all the things we stopped
working it's hard
basically just started enjoying our
lives more and not really focusing on
recruitment and
that that will happen you'll have those
periods and that was a lesson learned
like don't fall into that trap of
thinking everything's comfortable it
didn't affect us in the long run but
it got pretty close at times like we
were right we might
run out of money or whatever so um we
got quite lucky in that aspect but
i think again that's because we spent so
much time trying to work with these
businesses previously
and we built the personality side into
it so they wanted to work with us
when it came to it um um but yeah
i can't remember what your question is
that's it that's fine
so i guess look let let's dive back into
the last few years then where you've
really tried to go on this journey of
like growing your business right you've
got advice you're you're investing in
um things and stuff like that so i guess
what obviously we've been quite positive
so
let's just talk about what have been
since you've been getting advice and
really giving this a go and growing this
business
but what have been the sort of number
one and two biggest challenges for you
um the biggest challenges i suppose
would be adapting
to to new ways of doing stuff right so
i think previously when we were doing
ourselves we were never really metric
driven and we're still not a heavy kpi
business
but using those metrics right
to manage for the future look back over
the time what have we done at times of
success
what do we need to do in the future that
takes a bit of time and effort you know
and adapting to that mindset not trying
to go too like
religiously you've got to hit this every
single day because we're hopefully
hiring good enough people that can do
things learn the way and there are
different approaches but
adapting to the to the metric side of it
and i think
honestly the leadership side of it we
hadn't really had much
leadership experience and what have you
found much difficult about that then
because
like you said you've you and your
brother got the dni or um the
dna of looking after people being kind
to empathetic
like so i guess what have you found most
difficult have you found it difficult
to maybe i don't know maybe make the
hard decisions because
they've become like a bit of a mate or i
don't know what's what have you what
have you found difficult on the
leadership side
i think the things that found difficult
or
where perhaps getting better at it now
is just communication with everybody
um i think again you know like i said
start putting yourself in someone's
shoes so
as a junior person what you want to know
you want to know exactly where you stand
you want to know what you've got to do
to have success
and you want to be you're going to know
like you don't want to feel like you're
just doing something that's
a waste of time or you don't know what
you're doing basically so over
communicating
is is key when it comes to leadership
making sure everyone knows where they
stand
everyone knows how to progress everyone
knows how to have success
and then you have that channel and you
treat people with respect that leads to
kind of
more respect back and that's a really
good leadership trait there's nothing
worse than if you sat at your desk
your manager's just like well you know
get on phone
they said well give me a little bit of
help understand why behind it all and
how do we get that there and
so many people will go through that we
have we have regular just monthly
sit-downs right every month
people have quarterly or they have six
monthly it's so easy as a leader just to
sack that off or you know
we'll do it another day and it doesn't
happen but that that really gives people
suppose it makes the message clear on
what you want from them and where they
are and it gives them the energy as well
to
succeed themselves so communication is
one of the biggest things
i think yeah there's been times where
you make tough decisions but
i think then if you're if you're
obviously hiring inexperienced people
as a leader you've got to stay on top of
what they're doing not micromanage them
but you've got to know
you've got to keep a good mind out and
again that's communication if you
you can someone can see seem like
they're being dead quiet you know
they're not making any noise but
actually they're doing a load of good
work
so you can track that that's
communication again don't just sit there
getting annoyed because they're not on
the phone
they might be doing some really valuable
stuff in the in the meantime so
again that's communication from them to
you as well so
just keeping that keeping those channels
as clear as possible is like
you'll mess up because people become
disillusioned they've become annoyed
that they're not getting
communicated clear enough to um and
everyone wants that everyone wants to be
communicated too well they want to know
where they stand and i think that's the
key thing for sure yeah
no no i think and i think that's that's
become even more important in the sort
of
remote in the office at home as well
right so
i guess you've spoken really highly of
getting advice and that being quite
pivotal for you so
i'd be stupid not to ask you like what
have been
like maybe what's been like the most
impactful piece of advice that you've
applied to your business that you
probably
would have had to learn the hard way i
don't know what when i say to you what
have been the sort of most
instrumental one to free things that
have really enabled you and your brother
to push the business forward that
maybe would have taken you another two
years to work out what what comes up for
you
sure in all honesty right the the the
main thing it's pretty much the single
thing
is the the thing that we'd have maybe
figured out one day but still
we could be start hitting the same stuff
and
if you want to scale your business right
is you need to have
quite a few different things set in
place right so you have to be clear
on your mission or your purpose and what
is it that you want to do right and you
have to be able to convey that to
employees the candidates to clients this
is our mission right
then you need your vision what is the
blue sky thinking
what was it like in five ten years how
are we gonna get there right
and then you need your values is what
makes you
you you hire from those values you live
by those values
you you know you incentivize people
based on those values you make sure that
culture is
born out of the values that you set
because it's great it's very easy for
anyone just to go our cultures
you know we're pretty relaxed we're
pretty cool and take it easy but what
does that mean
you know what does that come down to in
behaviors
and if you list those behaviors and then
get them down it might be quite a lot of
different ones but then interview people
off those behaviors
that's how you create a scalable model
that would be one thing so the mission
vision values it's a clear thing and i
didn't know anything about this right
until we started discussing it all
um i think so just quickly on that
because like we're
just being honest here like where you
are as a business because where are you
how many of you are there at the moment
so the seven of us now and then we've
got another person starting
end of the month and i'm looking to get
two more on as well as soon as possible
yeah
because i think like i feel like someone
listened to this or someone
in where they are as that they may think
nah that's for bigger companies
so i just wanted to highlight that how
much of an impact let's have for you and
actually
you're a small grown business and that's
been one of the most impactful things
that you you still needed that despite
how big you are
yeah i mean it's absolutely it's
unbelievable yes it's like
it was essentially transformational
right and it's the most simple thing
but it is and it makes sense this is
what you're saying about those light
bulb moments you're like why haven't i
done that already you know it's obvious
yeah um another stuff there is get if
you if you're a business leader looking
to grow get a clear career path so
people know where they stand in the
business
black and white achievables on how they
get to where they want to be um
i think another thing i suppose we're
doing this already but act like you're
the bigger company
already right get your system sorted out
there's a balance
you can't spend all your time sorting
out systems but act like you're a bigger
company
put in the tools place ready to scale if
you if you want to scale your business
right
think about how we can get there so um
you know put
the processes in place like the systems
that you want make sure that's scalable
um get a crm if you just do it on
spreadsheets get an applicant tracking
system
um i think also and
potentially like advice i'd give to any
younger company we've been set up is
focus on marketing but don't put too
much into it get your basics set up
right get your shop window looking good
get get you get a few sales documents
sorted out you know get your
product proposals whatever it may be but
don't stress on the marketing too much
the marketing will come down
from from you dealing with your
customers right
um later down the line you can you can
you can deal with your marketing but
people who are very particular about
their brand can go and spend so much
time focused on marketing
and trying to make things look good that
they actually forget i've got to bring
the money in here
um and and you end up kind of making a
big mistake by
it's exciting isn't it it's like oh it's
my brand oh yeah we'll do the video
you'll spend half a day going she put
the logo here she put the logo there
i bet you've done this with recruitment
mentors right yeah yeah how does it look
look and i saw our linkedin update the
other day it was like never has anything
more
profound been done in marketing than
moving the logo a little bit to the
right
it's like it's like a joke so um yeah i
think i think kind of
your backtracking is get act like a big
company get all your vision and your
values in place so you have the core
behaviors get a career path
um get your marketing but don't take
your mind off what you need to be
getting done and that's getting yourself
out there building relationships with
good people and
you know essentially make bringing
revenue in and don't ever take your mind
off that and that was what feed the
company in the future
yeah nice and i hope you don't mind me
asking this but again people might be
thinking about it like
you don't have to give us the exact
figure but what's been the sort of
guide investment for you to get advice
or monthly support because what what's
what's been the relationship that you've
really got value from has it been like
the sort of ned point of view or has it
just been like a consultant that you've
engaged with you know i mean what's been
the sort of actual financial investment
because some people may be thinking well
i've spoken to people before and they've
charged way too much money so
what tell us a bit about that if that's
okay yeah i mean
like there's there's different ways to
look at it i think um the relationship
just answered the first part of the
question has been us
an nd consultant style okay relationship
um i mean the the investment um
can fluctuate obviously depending on the
amount of time that somebody puts in
um but you know a really good non-exec
director
out there is probably going to crop cost
anywhere between
maybe a thousand pounds or 750 a day to
2000 pounds a day
depending on how they how they gauge
their time um and you might not you
might need that person
a couple days a month at the start you
might need them a half a day
whatever it may be um my advice firstly
would be try and find people that will
give you advice for free
so yeah use your personality you know
engage with these people
um try and get little snippets of info
you know the big
stuff that you might need uh but when it
becomes apparent that you don't know
what you're doing and you've exhausted
all your other channels do that first
then you can start maybe finding someone
and getting that arrangement where you
pay them basically
yeah awesome thank you for sharing that
and on
on the investment side of things um
people always like to know like what
what's been some of the sort of best
tools or services that you've invested
in as a business
in your journey so far out of interest
um i've either helped you or helped you
your
that really helped your consultants yeah
i think um
hubspot was a big one for us okay so
it's um
crm so so we we have we use bullhorn as
an applicant tracking system
for all the candidate stuff but for the
um
i suppose the the client development
side of it
hubspot's been aced because you can you
can put all your contacts on there you
can
get different tools like there's it's a
really it's really good crm to be fair
um but there's
a small tool which was which was really
good is that we found that we
kind of the way we typically work is
we'll take a brief on
for from a client we're going to say
then the good people that don't get the
job we'll actually market them out to
good to good businesses right
taking more proactive approaches or
specking out as people call it
um in our market like i said before a
lot of it isn't done on switchboard and
there is numbers you have but it'll be a
good email so
what you can do on hubspot you can get
these things called sequences and
everyone
might already know this but it was about
two years ago we set up but
you can write your initial email and
then you can set
automated follow-ups to that email as up
to 10
and pick the time and date that you want
to send them and what we were finding
when we were doing marketing candidates
out it was actually maybe the second or
third time that we
followed up with them saying hey did you
have a chance to check out that profile
and then they were getting back to us
now if you can automate that and you can
automate that so at the start of the
week you can organize all of your bd or
on friday you can organize all of your
email bd for the following week you'd
have to lift a finger
it's going to lead to a lot more a lot
more save time
and a lot more efficiency with how
you're working so that was a good tool
um i think like you know
the other ones like you know everyone
uses linkedin don't they think tim
recruiters are
amazing for that stuff but you know then
the tools i suppose the tools is like
the peepers and the people that you're
you're training and
we train our guys to get referrals for a
lot of candidates right so asking your
network
again use your personality to get them
to give you information and that's what
that's the best people
um one of the juniors here she built 36
and a half grand
in march and been with us for seven
months
and two of those came from referrals um
two of those three placements two of
those came from referrals and it's just
like
that's what we want to see you know it's
minimal yeah not having to put as much
effort into it all
so you can have all the systems in the
world but unless you're doing the right
things yourself it's kind of
kind of pointless really and then even
on the crm stuff if you've not got the
right people the right contacts the
right data the right companies that you
mapped out
then it becomes pointless so
no no that was good so i guess to tie
this together then with
everything that you've learned so far
what like if you was
sitting down with me and i was someone
that was early on in my
sort of recruitment business journey or
thinking about it
at least and i was gonna take that first
step what would you try and communicate
to me
i'd be like right get your vision and
your value sorted out straight away
make sure you understand your market um
even
there's tools like fiverr now you can
jump on you know five of the the
good yeah you can get in contact with
someone you can give them a list of
companies and get them to go and find
those companies and send the spreadsheet
back to you right
like go on linkedin and do it all so get
your date if you're setting up from
scratch and you're doing it in a market
that you know obviously lean on the
people that you know but if you're doing
new markets because you've got
covenants find out map it out get people
to do the hard leg work for you because
it's cheap
get them on a get them on a good system
it's hubspot's free to use as well
and then you can explore the different
options that they have
and then make life as work as
efficiently as possible so you're not
having to do loads of legwork you feel
like it's taking too long or it's an
arduous process and it probably is
so there's there's ways you can simplify
it all
um but then honestly just get get to it
like work hard
focus um grind it out that's what you've
got to do when you're setting up the
business that's what the first years are
so important and really all it comes
down to is the
is the money that you bring in uh for
the future and then everything else
should fall into place but if it is like
that and you
you're doing it like a one-man band or
either two of you
get don't stop focusing on the on the
clients and the candidates and getting
making placements basically yeah
but i love that yeah so how talk to
talk to me about how are you viewing the
future you can talk about you guys as a
business like where you want to see
yourself in
the next five years and how are you also
thinking about the sort of future of
sort of the recruitment landscape and
and so yeah services that you're
delivering as a business
course right so a few different points
there but i was
we're constantly looking at this right
this is just in the way we do stuff
always looking at i think how we can
make things better and better and how we
can do things more efficiently and how
we can
even provide a better service to our to
our customers i'll look at this as a day
right and i'll sat there with someone
and the way we've always done it our
business is get people in and get them
to do the 360 recruitment role
now that has to be the 360 recruitment
role has to be one of the hardest jobs
in the world right i'm not even messing
you have to do so many different angles
and
and it's great listen for experience to
do that successfully fair play if anyone
does that successfully fair play to them
it's a tough job you're balancing so
many different things um
but for us as a business we're looking
at right now
what do our markets look at and there's
a lot of investment going into markets
when you get a lot of investment going
in from venture capital companies it
means growth
um and a lot of companies are now
popping up in our space but perhaps you
know
don't have the the sort of history that
we have with all so
the way we'll look to grow the business
and how we'll really scale the plan is
to get to 50 heads in the next five
years
and i think really where the scalability
will come in for us is
having the like a core sales team of the
people that we've got at the moment
right
working on a more exclusive and retained
basis so everyone's going through
retainer training
at the moment over the next um couple of
months to really
to up our game on that side and then
what the plans are is to build out a
delivery team basically i'm probably
giving away all
the secrets here but the essentially you
still have people doing 360 have a main
sales team have a delivery team and give
people the opportunity
in a market in a market that's growing
so much candidates are gold right we
know this yeah
so hire people who are great great with
people who who are interested who are
passionate who people want to work with
and create them put them on a clear
career path on how they can progress
through the candidate side of it all
because that's going to be the goal and
i think
you get really sharp you know ambitious
people into that environment you give
them the opportunity to move into a
sales role as well
but you level them up on the candidate
side teaching that side of earth they
can build amazing relationships with
senior candidates and they can go and do
the client side
it's not it's not really very different
um but have that constant funnel of
people
junior people coming in learning how to
do it our way and then
as they become more senior either lead a
team of delivery people
or move across into the sales side of
the business but you need to keep
that engine the problem we have is we
can't find a lot of people that we
want to hire that's the difficulty um so
but did you think do you think sort of
over the next couple of years
most recruitment businesses or most
recruiters will either find themselves
doing more of a focus client side role
or candidate side or do you think the
sort of 360
where which i was as well and most
people would listen to this or in that
sort of
environment do you think that'll still
exist yeah
i think it'll be the majority still in
all honesty i think um
it's it's weird isn't it as recruiters
we've got this mindset of like a little
bit us against the world which has
changed a bit but
i'm 360. it's my clients my candidates
i'm not sharing
whereas actually if you're if you're
really good at the bd side and landing
clients why not have support
you know why not give give half of your
fee away or however you structure it to
the delivery team because you can still
then focus on doing more
and go out and get more clients and
that's when you go from a kind of 200k
bill up to a 400 500k builder
so you have to hook it in and be ready
for that so yeah it's your question i
think i think it'll carry on it'll stay
for ages but
i think we'll have that for a while but
i think different skills
align themselves to different aspects of
the recruitment process right
so yeah um work work to the strengths
find the people that that can do the
different roles and
don't just turn someone down because you
think they might be shying clients when
they're great on candidates you know
what i mean
yeah absolutely so i've got some final
questions for you
okay before we finish so
first one is if you could change the
industry
what would you improve i
i i saw that one question the other
thing about it so what i do is
um add it's hard to explain but i try
and make
every what the the service levels a lot
better
a lot more like people working with
commitment i'd never have
people dropping fees just to get work
i'd really i suppose
it wouldn't say put barriers to entry
into the recruitment market because it's
stupid that's the whole
joy about it all but up everyone's game
right provide a better service bring the
reputation of the recruitment industry
back to actually being a good service
consultative service right
all the horror stories that you hear
it's not it makes bad lists and everyone
does things different ways right but
some of it's just awful so i would try
and remove
all of the sharky sheisty stuff and put
in great service great delivery
good relationships and and charging more
basically
yeah love that so what um what book have
you read recently or maybe a podcast you
listened to or maybe something you've
watched recently that's that's had a
had the biggest impact on you um
most of the books are read a fiction
book so oh wow okay
nice yeah so i'm not really honestly i'm
not massive on
the self-help stuff i listen to odd
podcasts and stuff but um
i find that these fans were but you can
learn a lot from actual like
make-believe stories
yeah for sure but you you take stuff so
but what's your life
yeah what's the maybe like really great
fiction book that's like had a really
lasting impact on you maybe well this is
more about this is more about like just
keeping positive there's a book called
catch 22. it's where the phrase catch 22
comes from right and it's just this
mad like it's like a it's like it's a
funny book a satire the quote right
it's just the frantic book of the
maddest story you've heard and
how these people in italy are in the war
and yeah it's there's you can only get
you can only you can only get out of
flying in the war if you're insane
the only way you can deflect be insane
is if you declare yourself insane but if
you declare yourself insane
you can't be insane right so that's the
catch 22 and you've got these guys
trying to get out flying because the
war's almost over but
just kind of makes me realizes that like
listen i suppose
life life's too short not to to have fun
and
be positive and enjoy it and be grateful
for everything that you have but reading
books like that make me maybe just make
kind of realize you got to have a bit of
fun with life right yeah yeah get down
you can
focus on all the bad stuff like at the
end of the day that'll all disappear
you've got to focus on the things that
that kind of make you happy that you
have a laugh that's what i like read
those types of books it doesn't have to
be depressing
yeah yeah i love that mindset positive i
love that
slightly it's a slightly different one
here then what what did you spend your
first biggest commission paycheck on
losing yeah well i don't think i bought
anything
and there's a good nightlife scene we
had a good group of
of people we all used to go out with
together so i was just um
yeah spending that on like clothes and
booze parking basically
fair enough final question what what's
the ultimate goal
for your recruitment career um
well this might change in a couple years
at the moment the ultimate goal for me
is to create a business
that is thriving where people really
understand like what they
what what they can achieve within our
company and progressing people's careers
within our business and creating future
leaders
making people a lot of money doing it
and having an environment that is
super positive that everyone's
everyone's buzzing to come into work um
and it's supportive of each other and i
think
creating that environment it's a goal
isn't it it's like it's blue sky
thinking but
for me to have that set up if you if it
five years time i was walking the office
and you know there's 50 of us in there
and everyone's buzzing everyone's
like talking about putting deposits on
houses what holidays have taken
everyone's like
really and then i guess on top of that
that comes down to providing that
perfect service
and that great service and being being
like respected in the industry for doing
what we do but we have a lot of positive
feedback from our clients we just keep
doing what we do and don't compromise on
those standards
um and yeah make sure everyone's
enjoying it as well and have have fun
doing it like you can get down sometimes
about it you've got to just keep
positive haven't you and
enjoy what you're doing basically i love
it james it's been an absolute pleasure
yeah thank you presentation take care
buddy